[Música]
generosidad en medio de la crisis
migrantes que hacen frente a Las bajas
temperaturas reciben ayuda de familias
de la fronteriza ciudad mexicana de
Matamoros la señora nos encontró también
así en la calle una noche que no
teníamos dónde y nos ofreció este
hospedaje o sea es algo que no hace
nadie Nosotros estamos muy agradecidos
me parece Me parece increíble y yo en mi
caso yo me siento muy agradecida con los
mexicanos y Y le doy las gracias de
parte de todos de los que están allá
también afuera del Refugio que reciben
día a día mucha ayuda ya sea de comida
de ropa de abrigo la saturación de los
albergues obliga a los que buscan
Refugio a quedarse afuera de la casa del
migrante San Juan Diego con siete grados
pero con una sensación térmica inferior
debido a las lluvias y los vientos
intentan sobrevivir Ofelia Pérez se
ofreció a abrirles las puertas de su
casa unas 20 personas muchas de ellas
niños les dije que no que pueden
quedarse más que ellos compren porque
pues yo soy la de los gastos de aquí no
me va a alcanzar también Rosario a una
escuadras intenta ayudar a quienes
dejaron atrás sus países Pues la verdad
pues viendo la necesidad de la gente
cómo están batallando
destaque colchón cobijas y les digo
cobijas comida y pues lo poquito que
tengo cientos de personas esperan la
oportunidad para poder cruzar hacia
Estados Unidos según la oficina de
aduanas y protección fronteriza en 2022
han sido detenidos 2,76 millones de
migrantes irregulares Pero esto no es
impedimento para que aún guarden la
esperanza de realizar el sueño americano